MICHEL DEGRAFF: I think I was
very lucky this time around
in this course to have students
from so diverse backgrounds.
But also students who,
I think most of them,
were first-generation
Americans and with ancestry,
either parents or grandparents,
from actually quite
diverse parts of the world.
From Mauritius, from
India, from Latin America.
And also in terms of
ethnicity and religion,
it was also quite a diverse set.
There were students whose
parents were Jewish.
There was an
African-American student.
There were some from India.
And they were
basically struggling
with these notions of who they
are in terms of their identity.
And can you be
Mauritian, but yet not
speak the Mauritian language?
Can you be Indian and
not speak Bhojpuri?
Can you be Latino, but
not be fluent in Spanish?
Can you be African-American,
but yet not
be fully fluent in
so-called Black English?
So those were questions that
they themselves brought in
that I think enriched the
course, because it became
very personal in many ways.
And I feel that
through this semester,
they themselves matured
in the kinds of answers
they were bringing to
these questions, which
were deeply personal.
And in fact, once I
discovered that they
had such diverse backgrounds,
and that the questions were
so personal in terms of who they
were as individuals, in terms
of identity, language,
religion, ethnicity,
then what I asked them to do
as the very first exercise was
to write what I call the
linguistic biography.
And actually, I am grateful
that I get this hint from a dear
friend and colleague Professor
Anne Charity Hudley who
teaches at UC Santa Barbara.
And Anne Charity
actually shared with me
her own linguistic biography.
And when I read that,
I realized how powerful
it was to read about
her own growing up,
in terms of language,
ethnicity, race.
So I thought that I
would ask students
to do something similar.
And that helped me
throughout the semester
to frame what kinds
of questions we
would answer throughout
the course, which
were very connected to
the essence of the issue
of language and identity.